way high ET this is Shania Twain here 25
years ago the budding superstar invited
us into her world I'm just signing
autographs I get the most thrill out of
making the music that's the most fun and
exciting part for me but when other
people recognize what it means so much
to you you know it just puts the icing
on the cake
[Music]
recording in the studio was new to
Shania at the time but she had always
been a performer
[Music]
growing up as Eileen Twain and Timmins
Ontario Shania started playing gigs at
just eight years old and as one of five
children in a home where money was
scarce she wanted to earn as much as
possible to help pay the bills I mean if
I had to get new guitar strings that
meant you know maybe we didn't get milk
you know and it really meant that you
know was very it was really touch and go
for a long time when we were kids and so
you know with me they had to make a lot
of sacrifices the sacrifices paid off
and the girl who changed her name to
Shania was on her way that don't impress
me just one year later Shania would take
home her first grand
I am totally overwhelmed I'm calling you
from the Grammys if you don't already
know I got the Grammy for best country
album I've never had so much attention
in my whole life and I'm loving every
minute of it
but years later the top-selling female
country artist of all time would be
singing a different in 2008 she's
separated from her husband and longtime
collaborator Mutt Lange after he had an
affair with her close friend she and I
revealed the betrayal in her memoir from
this moment on and in her own TV series
why not at the beginning I was very
tempted to just run away and never come
back yeah I was it's not like me to
share my private life it's on it's
stepping out of my comfort zone so of
course it makes me feel awkward
uncomfortable but my conviction and
reason behind doing it is definitely
stronger than the fear
[Music]
Paul they can break I am
our marriage wasn't the only thing that
was lost the stress along with what was
later diagnosed as Lyme disease affected
her singing I was slowly losing my voice
yeah
and that was a physical result or effect
of not you know expressing myself yeah
and restricting myself and the more
famous I got the more restricted myself
but that's manifested itself and that's
got to stop because you know I'm very
unhappy
not having my voice
[Applause]
with over 75 million albums sold Shania
announced a two-year residency at
Caesar's Palace in 2011 for first live
performance in seven years and she
started work on her fifth studio album
now which was later released in 2017
when writing something so personal what
did you learn about you really angry in
real life and when I'm writing this
stuff I'm probably swearing every third
word right right as I'm working through
all of the emotion that's really there
so then you know second line
[Music]
Vegas was supposed to be your last time
on stage in Las Vegas during the
residency I thought that that was gonna
be my last time doing concert then you
decided to do the final two no when you
announce this tour you also announced
that it would be your last tour are you
okay with saying goodbye well I don't
feel like I'm saying goodbye my every
night is going to be a goodbye every
night now you got a new record yeah well
you two were this yes I will you will I
will I really thought that would be the
only time I would be able to do that you
were good but I succeeded I was I was
because it was so much work yeah it
takes me an hour and a half just to warm
up for a show so it's exhausting but I
had more stamina than I thought yeah so
now that I've gotten in music I'm really
motivated to do that new music life and
this past December Shania did just that
returning to Vegas with her brand-new
residency Shania Twain let's go at
Planet Hollywood Resort and Casino
[Music]
[Applause]
what is this chapter mean in your
journey I'm at a point in my life right
now where I feel like there's not gonna
be enough life for me to really do
everything I want to do now
because I so many things have opened up
for me in the last couple of years now I
feel like it's endless like the
possibilities are endless
[Music]
you